[Musique]
ça a l'air tellement cool se faire
vacciner aux états unis et si le pic de
la troisième vague était déjà atteint
pour la première fois depuis des
semaines
certains indicateurs laissent entrevoir
une lueur d'espoir dans les dix-neuf
départements français où les mesures les
plus restrictives ont été prises le plus
tôt le 19 mars dernier des premiers
signaux encourageants sont constatées
qui jean christophe qui se demandent si
peut traverser la moitié de la france
pour suivre sa femme qui part en stage
pendant cinq semaines
alors là c'est compliqué pour ce pauvre
jean christophe étant donné que ce n'est
pas un motif professionnel pour lui il
suit son conjoint
alors voilà quand même qui conseille
personnel jean-christophe cinq semaines
vous pouvez laisser partir votre époux
ça fait du bien dans un coup au casting
j'ai eu une erreur de dire que le truc
qui pouvait me dérange et physiquement
ce que chez elle c'était une petite
bouée abdominale de temps en temps
et la paille très contente c'est quoi le
problème avec les bouées abdominale non
c'est parfait c'est parfait mais voilà
je parle de manière générale pour les
chanteurs quand est ce qu'on va nous
sortir des beaux mecs ou des belles ou
des fiches sublime bon quand vous
regardez au chili par exemple qu'un
talent incroyable l'indiscutable enfin
vous mettez un poster de o'shea dans
votre chambre ou mail effrayante
non mais non mais quand je dis ça j'ai
rien contre cette fille qui est génial
mais qu'elle donne ses chansons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
commence pas me faire chier non mais là
la sérieuse ça commence vraiment à me
casser les couilles
non non toi fermera définitivement c'est
ça être comédien professionnel doit
faire ce que ton coeur dit et tu dois
croire encore plus ce que tu crois
et quand tu commences à croire ce que tu
crois
la personne au monde qui peut te bouger
tu vas y c'est l'histoire d'un homme qui
n'a jamais renoncé même quand tout
semblait perdu
le 28 janvier ce pilote antonio sénat
d'école en direction d'une mine au coeur
de la réserve d'amazonie
mais son avion se crashe premier miracle
il est vivant mais il faut maintenant le
reste est à 36 ans il fait preuve d'un
sacré sang froid parce qu'avant de
quitter l'avion il récupère un couteau
une lampe de poche un bric à bref pas
grand chose
il décide d'attendre à côté de l'avion
en se disant que les secours vont bien
venir le chercher seulement voilà les
secours place mais il ne le voit pas sa
détermination paye après avoir marché
seuls 28 km il croise des cueilleurs de
noix qui vont le sauver
aujourd'hui antonio sénat la firme une
seule chose lui a permis de ne jamais
baisser les bras
l'amour pour sa famille que ce soir ses
erreurs elles sont elles sont ici à scop
arrêté et l'éclatement mère d'arrêter
cette histoire je parle du coeur ici on
n'est pas du show business
j'ai vu des premières émissions de télé
réalité quand je vivais entre entre la
france et les états unis
c'est un petit vie qui a démarré les
nantais avec des étudiants qui voyageait
dans un bus et qui vivait un sable qui
parcourait états unis évidemment il
vivait dans un camping car et se friter
tout le long de nos langues du show donc
c'est cesser pour moi ça m'intéresse pas
je sais la seule chose que j'aie
interdite mais nos enfants
[Musique]
quand on est sorti des limousines les sa
base auquel sabina sens du partage
je ne chante que la nôtre qui fait
beaucoup pas du tout c'est une légende
urbaine
mademoiselle grandit tellement vite que
j'étais un événement qui ne vont plus
merci j'espère qu'on va censurer ça
parce que temps plus tard tu va m'en
vouloir
pourquoi du papier toilette si je pense
savoir parce que cgt au moins au moins
deux semaines sans pouvoir perd à l'ats
que la commission quoi aider constipé
spéciaux assez y avait une caméra dans
les toilettes y avait une petite caméra
dans les toilettes
il ya quand même un probable pourquoi
une caméra dans les toilettes pourquoi
oui maintenant on le sait mais moi ça
m'a traumatisé 7 km
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr telle est la meilleure langue
pour dresser les chiens c'est l'allemand
parce que comme c'est une langue avec
une forte inflation ils le comprennent
très bien
du coup tu décides de leur parle en
allemand je me dis ok et vont voir que
je suis des leurs et ça va passer vous
dites c'est une armée de concentrer sur
eux mêmes exactement c'est à dire c'est
pas que la télé réalité c'est tout ce
que cela engendre derrière après on se
plaint qu'on a des gamins et des gamines
violente dans certains quartiers pauvres
qui essaient d'imiter tout ce qui est
clinquante tout ce qui est brillant et
de posséder des choses comme on leur dit
dans ses émissions là et qui n'y ont pas
accès qui accède par des moyens beaucoup
plus offensif la quête du gain popol
sont les molaires kirikou une flûte à je
suis assez inquiet choqué les tasers ils
trouvent ça cool ma chance ça non est ce
qu'elle est à l'image de la tienne je ne
suis pas l'habitude de manger des
carottes donc oui le beau temps que
j'aime et la tienne j'avoue que elle est
délicieuse
excusez nous mais on peut savoir ce qui
vous fait rire
mais c'est vrai t'as garros et genre de
gars que je peux manger tous les jours
ma mère appelle alexia laroche joubert
et alexia laroche joubert a lui dit
écoutez vous n'allez pas nous faire
chier votre fille a gagné assez d'argent
avec l'oeuvre
donc ça sert à rien que voilà donc qui à
un moment donné il ya le revers aussi de
la dollar je veux dire il ya les
coulisses et ya la raya ce qu'on montre
à la télévision